le stif très bon jour pour ceux qui me
connaissent déjà je vous savez que je
suis je suis amateur de langues et un
moteur de l'apprentissage des langues
j'aime beaucoup apprendre des langues
j'en parle disons 15 16 et dont le set
que j'ai appris après après l'âge de
soixante 60 ans maintenant j'en ai
maintenant 70 et bien et puis maintenant
je suis dans un à ce qu'on nous appelons
à link elle ing q c'est notre site pour
l'apprentissage des langues
nous avons une espèce de ce qu'on
appelle le défi des 90 jours
challenge défi de 90 jours où nous
voulons que nous apprenons nous nos
apprenants nos membres se concentre sur
l'apprentissage d'une langue et qui font
davantage d'efforts pour que chaque jour
il soit là a étudié à écouter à lire
enfin faire tout ce qu'il faut pour
apprendre
moi j'ai choisi locaux rien c'est une
langue que c'est pas la première fois
que je m'attaque aux coréens mais je
fais des progrès et chaque jour je
raconte peu ce que je fais ce que je
ressens comme comme progrès en fin et
tout mais il se trouve que
il y à il ya quoi dix jours ma femme a
dû subir une opération pour ses oignons
bagnasco mondiaux l'anglais est là sur
un pied et que maintenant elle est un
peu immobilisé donc moi je dois faire
les repas préparés les repas faire la
nourriture et j'ai commencé à raconter
un peu ce que je fais et je vais faire
ça aujourd'hui en france est d'ailleurs
puisque le parlent français ce soir je
viens de recevoir ma carte de membre de
l'association des anciens élèves de
sciences po et j'ai fait sciences po 1
60 65 65 66 64 à 66 la rue saint
guillaume à paris c'était les années
merveilleux merveilleuse et je garde de
très très beaux souvenirs de mon séjour
en france et j'y vais tous les quelques
années et avec ma femme et elle aime
beaucoup ce pays
bon ce que je sais ce qu'est ce que j'y
préparer là pour ma femme
d'abord j'étais un peu occupé on avait
un rendez vous avec mon fils qu'il y ait
le disons le le chief operating officer
je sais pas comment ça se dit en
français de link et on était on était
allé se rencontrer avec une université
où vas y vas peut-être y avoir une
coopération ça on verra bien donc je
souhaitais un peu tard à entrer chez moi
moi j'ai une espèce de d'esprit
utilitaires quand il s'agit de de la
bouffe de prépa il faut que ça soit bon
bien sûr mais quand je vois ce qui reste
dans le frigidaire j'aime toujours
essayé d'utiliser ce qu'il y a donc
j'aime beaucoup les légumes donc oui
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des poires ont
donc ça s'appelle rouge
il y avait
du radicchio pourraient pas commencer à
se dire en français il y avait des
endives
il y avait du fenouil puis moi là j'ai
coupé tout ça j'ai mélangé ça dans une
espèce de bol de salade avec de l'huile
d'olive sel les poires et c'est un peu
de persil j'ai pas pourquoi parce qu'il
fallait aussi utiliser le persil qu'on
en avait enfin pas mal de frières j'ai
mis tout ça dans le four mis ça avec le
lire et tout ça à jenny quelques enfin
temps de terre que j'ai chauffé dans le
micro ondes un petit peu là principe
mettre sur le plat que je mets dans le
four j'ai mis ça dans le four pour 30
minutes
par la suite j'ai aussi pris des
batteries parce qu'il en restait dans le
frigidaire je voulais m'en débarrasser
là aussi les ennemis je les ai mis dans
le micro-ondes peu comme par la suite
sur le même plan dans le four ensuite ma
femme m'a dit de couper les champignons
qu'on avait qui était aussi un un peu
vieux puis elle a m'a aidé parce qu'elle
a pris on avait aussi dû de la viande de
dinde au on avait acheté la papa
tricheurs des tranches assez mince
qu'elle a donc est là il a fait le show
faire chauffer d'abord les oignons dans
la poêle
ensuite dès les champignons puis ensuite
des tomates que j'ai coupé point g coupe
est aussi vain tout ce qu'il fallait
faire le travail c'est moi qui la fait
parce qu' elle ne peut pas rester debout
très longtemps et donc j'ai coupé tout
ce qu'il fallait couper et l'a mis dans
la poêle et puis elle a fait sa com donc
il y avait donc deux places et j'ai même
pris les photos que je vais montrer et
voilà ce que et on la mange et c'est
avec un bon vin de l'okanagan
la vallée à l'intérieur ici dans notre
province
la colombie-britannique et c'est un vin
qui coûte 15 16 $ qui est très bon et
après ça parce que il y a quelques
semaines j'avais mais peut-être une
semaine j'avais ft adil fromages chez un
fromager et thierry dut donc du match au
bout de 12 mois
une espèce de fromages bleus français
sainte agathe
il m'avait dit le nom j'ai oublié puis
un autre fromage français et nous les
fromages fins d'assécher au canada mais
chaque chaque soir quand on les mange on
mange d'aider des tranches assez mince
donc ça dure
quand même une semaine puis avec lover
aussi larmes
une beauté volée pour nous ça dure au
moins deux jours et puis j'ai la pompe
pour que ça se gâte en france et en
europe
comme d'habitude et demain il va falloir
faire autre chose mais voilà un peu
l'explication de ce que je fais pour un
autre dîner mais mon intérêt principal
faire la bouffe aussi mais c'est
l'apprentissage des langues et je vais
continuer dans cette série en racontant
comment japon le coréen
merci beaucoup